THE FRONT LINE,
BETTER ENERGY.
SENGUN STEPH'S
WE HAVE TO SEE THAT AGAIN.
HOW DOES STEPH
BEHIND THE BACK!
JOCK LANDALE FINISHESS DUNK
COURTESY OF LONNIE WALKER.
HE GOTMOVE WITHOUT THE
BASKETBALL.
>> HE CHECKS IN.
LOOK AT THIS PASS.  STRAIGHT
YEARS.P ABOUT JOKICFOR GORDON,
AND HIS SECOND.
HE'S INTO DOUBLE FIGUNOT SURE
THERE WAS ONE, BUT LOOK AT
NIGH
KEPT GUYS IN FRONT AND FOULED
AND REACHED AND A JASON WILLIAM
TYPE PASS.
THAT WAS S  IGNITE
COACH, BRIAN SHAW, WHO'S WITH  .
MAN,ARKET THEM.
A BRIL
SO MANY TIMES, GARLAND ADDS NOTS
AS WELL AS REDDISH TO STEP GO A
WITH THE SPLIT.
THEY HUSTLE S GETTING IT BACK.
THAT'S THE MOST ANNOYING THING
HE AVERAGED ALMOST 11 PER GA
AND THEN THE DISH. THE ALLEY-OOP